there will be spoilers in this video so
make sure you've seen unbreakable and
split and glass before watching if you
want to hear my theory about the meaning
behind the clover tattoos then stick
around to the end of this video
glass begins with four cheerleaders
being abducted by Hedwig and David Dunn
who is starting to become known as the
overseer shifting his focus from petty
criminals to the Horde we first see him
take out these kids who are filming
themselves Superman punching a random
guy in the street to try to go viral
these low criminals are pretending to be
superheroes online which provides a
stark contrast with the ending of glass
where real superheroes leak on social
media David now has his own security
company done home security Elijah says
an unbreakable that David works in
security for a reason because he's a
born protector so it makes sense that he
gets his own company you could have been
a tax accountant you could have owned
your own gym you could have opened a
chain of restaurants you could have done
one of 10,000 things but in the end you
chose to protect people you made that
decision and I find that very very
interesting the next day at work M night
Shyamalan the director of the trilogy
makes his cameo appearance and it
answers one of the questions I had going
into the movie he mentions that he's
getting more cameras because one of his
tenants was killed off sites he's
talking about dr. Fletcher so it seems
that Jay from split wasn't just an IT
guy helping dr. Fletcher review security
footage but actually her landlord and
probably also her landlord just spin the
wheel dummy
Jay goes on to see David and he
recognizes him as the security guard
from all those years ago and tells him
that he used to hang out with the shady
types at the stadium but he turned his
life around this confirmed that Stadium
drug dealer and Jay are in fact the same
character but this is more than just a
fun little directors cameo it shows the
effect that David had cleaning up crime
around his city he actually had a
positive impact on the community and
helped turn shady people into
functioning members of society David
goes out again to look for the hoard
with Joseph giving him tips via
headphones and GPS tracker not only is
this a common superhero trope but it's
also a concept that Shyamalan used in
his 2013 film after earth although in
that movie the roles were reversed and
it was the father giving advice to his
son after David bumps into Hedwig on the
street he heads towards
the brick factory to look for the girls
and the word allies is written in
graffiti on a window in the background
foreshadowing the teaming up of Elijah
and the Horde that sounds like the bad
guys take me on give me unbreakable
things you missed I discussed how upside
down camera composition was used to
foreshadow bad things happening and the
trend seems to continue in glass when
David has the confrontation with the
Beast we see the beasts point of view as
he crawls along the ceiling towards
David and the rescue cheerleaders like
many super villains the Beast has a
signature move which is fittingly a
giant bear hug this is the same attack
he used on dr. fletcher during split on
david during the factory fight and the
orderly when him and mr. glass are
escaping throughout the series broken
glass is used as a metaphor of the
well-being of the characters so when
David and the Beast battle sends them
out the factory threw a shattering glass
window it spells the beginning of the
end for them because it leads to their
capture and placement in Ravenhill
Memorial once we arrive at that
institution that there's a huge clue
about the final twist of the movie as
they're placed in their rooms we are
shown the point of view of the cameras
placed around the institution the entire
movie these security camera shots are
constantly being shown the final twist
is dangled in front of us all along the
characters are introduced to their new
psychiatrist dr. la staple at the end of
the movie we find out that dr. staple is
part of an ancient organization created
to suppress superheroes from the public
when that happens she tells mr. glass
that they don't take sides she's not
good or evil she essentially falls in
the middle in a literal comic book there
are staples placed in the middle crease
to hold everything together her name
represents for neutrality KC gets word
of the beast capture once she's pulled
aside at school and we also see that she
attended the same school as Joseph Dunn
I'm not entirely sure what the point of
that was outside of furthering the idea
that everything is connected in a comic
book story much like how david and
clarence w crumb were on the same train
which as a quick side note clarence his
name continues the theme of alliteration
in the first two movies with characters
like david dunn KC cook Kevin prom and
now Clarence cross there's also a
character I noticed in the IMDB credits
called Scarlett shields I honestly have
no idea who that even
I'm assuming she's a minor character but
basically every other minor character
has a name like hospital patient or
cheerleading girl number four I honestly
have no idea who this is supposed to be
maybe she was just given a name to throw
people off trying to look up information
online before the movie came out
or maybe she's given a name because she
has an actual nametag somewhere in the
movie let me know your findings in the
comments David's son Joseph meets with
dr. staple to try to convince her to let
David go free when he is unsuccessful
the camera tilts down to an upside down
position again to watch Joseph leave the
facility just as Joseph saw the original
train crash footage upside down on the
couch and unbreakable this camera
movement and glass also represents
impending disaster and speaking of
unbreakable when I saw the scene of
David coming into a young Joseph's room
I was completely blown away by it
because I somehow had no idea that these
deleted scenes from the first film
existed and this one works really well
considering the themes of glass let's
roll it scared
that's great know why
you know no no what
yes she could identity so Joseph felt
uneasy about the fact that his father
has these incredible abilities that
can't be explained but finds comfort in
knowing that he has someone to protect
him this helps explain why it was so
important for mr. glass to outsmart the
black clover society and broadcast the
existence of superheroes out to the
world
next KC is given the opportunity to meet
with the Horde and discovers that her
touch can bring Kevin forward into the
light my theory as to why KC has this
ability it relates to the fact that the
additional identities were created by
Kevin's brain as a coping mechanism for
the abuse dished out by his mother it
stated in split that the Horde exists to
protect Kevin are you in charge
yeah we've taken charge we're the only
ones that can protect Kevin we're all
here to protect Kevin he's very weak so
naturally the way to bring down these
protections is with love and kindness
Casey is the only one who's capable of
this because she too has been abused by
her uncle so she knows what kind of
gentle hand is needed to undo the damage
when Casey leaves the institution after
that she puts on the jacket given to her
by the man working at the Philadelphia
Zoo who helps us court her out of danger
at the end of splits my guess is that
she still wears that jacket as a
reminder of how she stood up to the
Beast something that also gave her the
strength to stand up to her uncle and
just be a stronger braver person overall
in the final examination scene and dr.
staple tries to convince mr. glass the
Horde and the overseer that they don't
actually have superpowers by giving
rational explanations for everything
that's happened and telling them that
they'll remain institutionalized for the
rest of their lives if they're unable to
overcome their disorder in a way she's
actually telling the truth although we
don't know it yet the black clover
Society was actually planning to kill
them if dr. staple didn't successfully
convince them that they're ordinary in a
three-day timespan but I'll get back to
the black clover Society later in this
video
dr. staple tells David that he has the
symptoms of the supposed superhero
disorder but lacks some kind of
anchoring incident that made him realize
that he was a superhero which is funny
because the anchoring incident he thinks
of is literally him drowning like an
anchor one of the main talking points
that dr. staple uses to try to convince
them that they're ordinary is that if
superheroes do exist then why would
there only be the three of them this
dr. staple counting on the fact that her
black clover society will always be
successful in suppressing any supers
from the public eye David and Patricia
appear to have their faith in their own
powers shaken Elijah doesn't respond
because he's pretending to be a
vegetable but he knows that dr. staples
lines
all the talk of comic books sends Casey
to the comic book store to do some of
her own research and the store is owned
by none other than the comic book store
clerk from unbreakable it seems that his
suspicions of pervs in the back of the
store hasn't changed either
when he yells out to Joseph you better
not be one of those Hello Kitty purrs
[Music]
you better not be jacking off to the
Japanese comics I swear to God just as
the mirror reflection shots are used to
introduce a villains and unbreakable and
split similar shots are used in glass to
show that something is not right
David sits on the floor of his cell and
his reflection is distorted by the
curved wall across the way the hoard is
seen in a distorted reflection to
recurved mirror it is shortly after this
that we discover Elijah was faking his
sedation and he has the ability to sneak
out of his room where he discovers the
magazine advertising the opening of
osaka tower just as the previous movies
had subtle references to the Fantastic
Four and teen titans the headline of
this article calls osaka tower a true
marvel Elijah tells the Beast that his
plan is to attack the tower on its
opening day to December 7th which is
Pearl Harbor day another major American
disaster more importantly that's also my
birthday so put that down in your
calendar right now right now then we get
a glimpse into Elijah's past when he
sneaks on to a carnival ride and tries
to protect himself using stuffed animals
but again it works really well here
because the Beast ends up protecting him
from the orderlies and the police as
they break out of the hospital so it's
kind of as if he's been protected by
animals every step of the way it's also
interesting to note that his plan on a
carnival ride backfires and he ends up
breaking his shoulder just as the Beast
turns on him at the end of glass and
breaks his shoulder an injury he would
never overcome after Elijah discovers
the powers of the Beast he formulates
his plan to have the beast battle David
in front of the world I think it's
important to note that it was never mr.
glasses real intention to go to the
tower all he really needed to do was
convince the Beast to break them out so
he could stream it using the cameras
mr. plan and for anyone who felt that
David Dunn's part in all of this was a
little underwhelming let's not forget
that it was most likely done security
company who provided all the cameras to
the institution in the first place
part of Elijah's plan was to change out
the lens of the machine that he used for
his surgery then get himself caught
lollygagging around on camera so that
the doctor moves up the date of his
operation this is important because it
allows the orderly Darrell to let his
guard down around Elijah giving him the
opportunity to slit his throat with a
broken shard of glass and it just as
Elisha's of broken glass kane
represented his injuries and unbreakable
the broken picture frames foreshadow his
eventual demise in glass all three
characters have their broken glass
moment at the end of the second act
there are a couple more clever uses of
shots that use mirror reflections to
tell us something the first is dr.
staple getting out of her car and
heading in to Ravenhill memorial which
we see through her side mirror these
mirrors always come with a disclaimer
objects in mirror are closer than they
appear
well dr. staple is not just a
psychiatrist as she appears to be but
she's actually part of this secret
organization our earlier mirror shots of
David in the hoard are distorted by
curved mirrors but when Elijah finally
meets the Beast he first sees the
transformation through the reflection of
the glass cabinet and there's no
distortion here which tells us that
things are going to be essentially as
they should be with the impending clash
of good versus evil then dr. staple
realizes that Elijah is broken out and
she sees the news report on TV about the
opening of osaka tower and thinks mr.
glass is going to sabotage it also the
reporter is the same guy who reports on
the missing girls and split and on the
news ticker at the bottom there's a
report about cryptocurrency Krypton is
the name of Superman's home planet and
Superman has referenced several times
throughout glass shortly after the final
battle begins and dr. staple curiously
tells someone to make sure to keep
patients and staff away from the
Southside windows this is because she
knows that david elijah and kevin's
powers are real and it's her duty to
make sure nobody finds out about them so
that brings us back to this whole black
clover society who are they where did
they come from why do they have these
matching tattoos and what do they have
to do with split and unbreakable all of
the answers to these questions are
coming up
at the end of the confrontation a
mysterious group of SWAT members all
sharing a risk tattoo of a black three
leaf clover shows up to kill David and
the Beast dr. staples revealed to be
part of the society she explains that
they are a group that's been around for
10,000 years to keep superheroes out of
the public eye because it's not fair to
the rest of society to have gods walking
among us dr. staples mission the entire
time was to get them to believe that
their powers weren't real so they can go
on living ordinary lives she was given
three days to do so but if she failed
the alternative was some kind of brain
surgery or death in splits we are shown
how the organisation's manipulation of
society has worked Society sees the
hoards dissociative identity disorder as
a problem a mental illness that needs to
be cured dr. Fletcher's thesis to the
medical community is that maybe those
with those condition are actually
extraordinarily gifted well we look at
people who've been shattered and
different as less than but if they are
more than us but dr. Fletcher is largely
rejected by her peers and it's because
of the black Clover society that's been
working for 10,000 years to condition us
to see this as a mental illness that's
exactly what dr. staple does in glass
she rounds up three of the most
extraordinary supers in Philadelphia and
tries to convince them that something is
wrong with them and that they need
treatments that's why she wants Casey to
get Kevin to hold on to the light
because she is aware of the power that
someone with a D ID is capable of the
existence of this group also explained
the question brought up way back when
Elijah and David have their first
meeting in unbreakable I believe comics
are last linked to an ancient way of
passing on history the Egyptians drew on
walls countries all over the world still
pass on knowledge through pictorial
forms remember when dr. staples meeting
with Joseph Casey and Elijah's mother
and tries to convince them that comics
are nothing more than fantasy she even
brings up comic book conventions to try
to invalidate them the only time she
gets frustrated is when they try to link
their situation to what they've seen in
comic books the clovers Society is there
to ensure that these stories exist
through pictures as seemingly fictional
stories but nothing more
comics are a form of history that
someone somewhere felt or experienced
then of course those experiences and
that history got chewed up in the
commercial machine got jazzed up made
titillating cartooned for the sale rack
in glass that someone somewhere is
Elijah referring to his mother and
Joseph and Casey only this time instead
of distributing comics to be chewed up
in the commercial machine they have
actual video evidence of the existence
of these powers doctor staple also
mentions that when one super appears
another is likely to appear opposite of
him and it just leads to conflict which
is why she feels that the clover society
needs to appear to pacify them if
there's someone like me in the world and
I'm at one end of the spectrum couldn't
there be someone else
opposite of me at the other end someone
who doesn't get sick doesn't get hurt
with the rest of us and he probably
doesn't even know it okay but why the
black clover tattoos that seems kind of
random well maybe not we can look at it
from the secret organizations
perspective and from a filmmaking
perspective first from a filmmaking
perspective the fact that David Elijah
and the hordes journey as super-powered
humans ends with the tattoo of these
clovers kind of brings the trilogy full
circle let's go way back to when we're
introduced to David and unbreakable a
woman appears asking him if he's alone
and she takes the spot next to him on
the train he notices a tattoo on her
abdomen which appears to be a rose but
we only see the bottom of the stem
because this is the very root of David's
story when we see the secret societies
clover tattoos at the very end of
David's story we're seeing the top of
the plant so it's almost as if we've
come all the way around but then why not
use a rose tattoo for the society as
well the clover does a better job of
representing their values they
essentially want to purge the world of
anyone who has these rare special powers
a four-leaf clover is considered a rare
and lucky find much like how a super
hero is a rare incredible standout in
our society but the black clover people
don't want that they want everyone to be
a three leaf clover and that's why it
was chosen as the symbol of their
organization finally there was one other
minut detail that I felt really brought
the series to a nice conclusion mr.
glass famously gets his supervillain
name from the kids that made fun of his
condition osteogenesis imperfecta
Elijah's mother lives across from a
playground we see this in a flashback
during unbreakable at the end of glass
before the email comes from Elijah
containing the footage of the final
battle you can hear the sounds of
children playing outside how fitting
that the very playground that the kids
poked fun of Elijah at part of what put
the villain idea in his head in the
first place gave him his awakening as a
super villain can be heard again just
before Elijah's mother puts out that
video to help all the heroes and
villains across the world have their
realization and awakening when David
first accepts his newfound powers and
unbreakable Elijah tells him to go where
there are people and he goes to the
train station that's exactly what mrs.
Pryce and Joseph and KC do when they
unveil the existence of these comic-book
heroes to the world if you enjoyed this
video you can check out my things you
missed episodes on unbreakable and split
as well and make sure you subscribe to
seize these worlds for new Horrors every
week ring that death bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive